oh my god it's happening what's up
reject nation I'm Greg Alba what's your
name
my name is M don't struggle nation
struggle nation and real rejects are
colliding five people care about this we
are to it now if you guys haven't seen
struggle nation there a huge reaction
channel you guys almost like 500k right
now right well I think we're at 4:15
doesn't like I think we're at 4:15 638
you know give it two thousand we
actually know each other through aqus on
right mm-hmm and we met up at comic-con
and we hung out unfortunately we got
along again so now he's here cuz he
lives in California he almost had my old
place almost almost anyway no one really
cares about this as much as we do let's
hop right into this you caught it
Chapter two
yes I did did you like it I did I did
I'd like to but in the first one you
didn't opinions are subjective to really
stir eggs you missed an it Chapter two
considering that it's based off of
really huge novel I'm sure there's
plenty of things that flew right over my
head let's get into this do it in
Chapter two is finally branched into
theaters bringing the long bloody saga
of the losers Club to a close
well we're not leaving the circus just
yet with a nearly three hour runtime and
a thousand-page book to reference there
were found to be plenty of Easter eggs
in in Chapter two here are the ones you
might have missed okay it chapter two
had a lot of catching up to do well the
first film focused exclusively on the
kids and it aside the dual job of both
introducing the adult versions of the
losers and making you believe that they
really could be those children all grown
up we're introduced to adult Ben Hanscom
we see a boardroom with a bunch of men
arguing over the model of a building
after the camera slides over the room it
finally focuses on one man it's Ben
except it's not been as portrayed by Jay
Robin is on a Skype call with everybody
in that room but it's a double fake out
because that first guy was Ben all grown
up
abused C was Brandon Crane who played
Ben Hanscom
oh the fears of your childhood give it
an actor the chance to play both a child
and an adult oh that's uh no they focus
on only who's that speaking of cameos
there was a special one they're fans of
Stephen King probably that's so cool
alone over the heads of casual viewers
no not the one where director Andy
muschietti appeared in the background
when any visits the Derry pharmacy of
course about kingdoms yeah
the horror author showed up is the owner
of second hand rose the thrift store
yeah yeah like kings portrayal in the
film prior in the novel but that's not
the end in the film the shopkeeper has a
copy of bills book attic room on his
desk after bill notices the book he
repeats what everyone else says about
bills books he doesn't like the end yeah
that's a joke that's overused in the
movie but hearing the criticism pens
just to the page up is a pretty great
nod it was funny that all readers don't
like the endings of Kings books she goes
let's face it they're not always great
okay one character the film is out
entirely is maturing an ancient
intergalactic turtle that sort of helps
the loser's bastard despite a better
about what competing its timeline bill
performs the ritual up should with
Pennywise and ends up soaring to a
cosmic realm beyond space and time at
which point he encounters a big old
turtle but already comes from the same
dimension as the being known as it and
in fact created our world by puking it
out when he had indigestion so good
thing the macro verse doesn't have
pepto-bismol well neither of the itch
gnomes have dared to quite go into that
level of cosmic craziness they've
definitely dropped a few turtle Easter
eggs in Chapter one for a Lego turtle in
Georgie's room that was a mention of a
turtle at the quarry where the kids go
swimming in Chapter two we see a model
of eternal at Derry elementary yes
I really set out to more scattered
around the bill we wouldn't be surprised
in an effort to double down on bills Gil
did not be able they should put the
turtle and their one extra saving the
kid shows up three times in the film but
in the novel he only appears once in
bill is wandering around darienne
revisits the old sewer opening where
Georgia became penny wise as lunch bill
notices the kid with a skateboard and
urges him to stay away from the sewers
because there are killer clowns afoot if
you pay close attention to the underside
of deep skateboard who can see that
although it's a little roughed up it
once had the same design as the
overlooked hotels carpet and stanley
kubrick's out of it oh really
how would you notice that yo losers
finally track Pennywise down to its
underground lair and totally flood the
ritual up should the clown gets them all
to scatter one by one they all relive a
twisted surreal version of their
childhood beers Beverly's nightmare
takes on the form of a stall in a school
bathroom yeah that's a lot like the one
where she got trash dump daughter in the
beginning of the first video this dog
clearly symbolizes some sort of cage
because from over the years most of my
life history about 27 years Tim Curry
was the definitive creepy clown and no
modern adaptation worth insulted Pitt
means is going to ignore it completely
in it chapter one we get to see a clown
with a striking resemblance to Tim
Curry's Pennywise in the scene where
Ritchie explores the house on nibel
Street and in a sequel we got even more
nods to the mini series for starters one
of the most iconic
hey why's pops up with one of the most
well-known songs from the 1990 version
you know the water and the canal days
festival bill chases a young boy into a
clown themed funhouse and runs into a
room full of swinging clown max look
closely and you can find the Royals at a
second pen is the outfit from Curry's
Pennywise I mean those that have
eyebrows you got to pay attention
physically they each carry remnants of
their childhood into adulthood with them
in Eddie's case he grew up into a man
who couldn't quite bear to leave his
mother behind so we marry her okay
not literally but Eddie's wife Myra is
physically and sometimes spiritually a
doppelganger of his mother she's big
needy domineering and fixated on her
husband's welfare points of emotionally
traumatized just like mom
angers okay because they were playing
down here I'm serious
in Chapter two we only saw a miracast
rack briefly but sharp-eyed viewers may
have noticed a very very specific detail
namely she's portrayed by the same
actress who plays Eddie's mother in both
films Molly Atkinson okay you've got a
weird feeling in your stomach thinking
that Eddie's wife looked a little too
freely mom you weren't wrong what if you
had to name two mainstream porn that's
crazy I did not know that or you'd be
quick to come up with two names Stephen
King that's gnarly
both are prolific writers and both have
been writing published fiction for about
the same length of time obviously the
two authors have taken notice of each
other over the years now while they
probably don't have a kind of rivalry
fans think they do
they haven't been adverse to taking
shots at each other over the years just
like you and I yeah all the time who
watches over an incarcerated Henry
Bowers that scene where he's introduced
involves an observation from the
perspective of Henry Bowers that quote
Koontz is the worst in it Chapter two
hoots is alive and well with an
especially fitting appearance he's in a
boy at juniper Hill and you can spot him
in the film at the guard watching a dog
video Oh how's that funny cuz of course
he is dogs are magical they're more
magical than elves in the kids Ben
Hanscom is scared of The Mummy
while Ritchie's fears take the form of
the hairy shape-shifter from I was a
teenage werewolf and the uzi peeper from
a 1958 creature feature called the Koala
die because who wouldn't be scared of
that
but with updated times come updated
scares and it appears that these
eighties kids found some new monster
movies to be scared of something like
john carpenter's 1982 for masterpiece oh
god yeah refresher the thing is about a
shape-shifting alien that plates a
research team in Antarctica it's discuss
anything that impacts and what an eighth
chapter two is more members
Mitchy Eddie come across Stan's
decapitated head in a fridge yeah the
other thing yeah almost immediately the
head grows a bunch of freaking spider
live Ritchie says you've got to be
kidding me
it's a fitting tribute to the sewer
rustlers forecast which sees one of the
researchers lose his head to the
tentacle monstrosity
after which palmer says you guessed it
it's a disturbing you gotta be kidding
wasn't correct I always know if he says
a few shows up in the house on eyeballed
Street and run into a variety of clown
flavor or spectacles certainly the most
memorable segment from at C's Ritchie
and bill based with the scary doors
thinking on their feet they first run to
the door labeled not scary at all and by
that surprise it's pretty scary inside
they see one of the missing girls
hanging by her hands with everything
below her waist missing well it takes 27
years but Ritchie eventually finds those
Latin zip when they're back in the ninth
house as adults Ritchie again comes up
against the three scary doors and the
first one he opens reveals a pair of Tor
soulless legs Skippy ah I did not
connect yeah technically this Easter egg
breaks through the universe of the film
and into our world which is even
creepier okay so it's not that creepy
but it's still pretty cool most King
fans know that he's big on the number 27
and it in particular uses the number as
a main plot point
Pennywise comes back every 27 years it
makes sense then that in chapter 2 saw a
release date of September 6 2009 teen if
you break 9 6 2019 down number by number
all the digits add up to 27
coincidence either desire after one
released on September 8 2017 follows the
same formula all the digits in the day 9
8 2017 equal exactly 27 well and to that
the fact that the first film was
released 27 years after the 1990
miniseries and well things are starting
to get a little freaky here check out
one of our newest videos right here hi I
guess it's coincidence I mean it may be
particularly I you never know maybe
they'd be looking to the movies the
movies have Friday release dates that's
the way it goes it's close to Halloween
what if it did it at home
now numbers we sure did it would have
none of the Friday's in
september/october added at 27 I think
maybe that was coincidence and aid they
kind of wanted to make it seem like it
was part of it yeah I plan thinking like
that I just randomly know I mean I
imagine that there's way more Easter
eggs than what was mentioned here but
there's some pretty cool ones I came
here yeah yeah you know I gotta clarify
something - I did a review for a chapter
two and I clearly wasn't very positive
about the frilly yeah I was like 50/50
on the film overall that's not to say I
don't appreciate it because I think it's
pretty crazy to have like this horror
franchise that's this big and this
intricate yeah massive on a global scale
it's a cool time to be living in and a
half such an like this is the first epic
horror franchise that I could think of
like a three-hour horror film that
everyone's tuning in for that's pretty
nuts to me so I do appreciate it and if
the director has said that he wants to
shoot a couple more scenes and make a
cut that's more similar to the book
we're cutting back and forth from the
adults and the kids the whole time and I
would be down and watch that at my home
yeah because like I've complained that I
could really have about is you felt the
runtime yeah usually I don't that's all
in-game like about 15 times I didn't
feel but this one I kind of felt the
runtime of it a little bit like it's a
good comparison and gaming it chapter 2
or very similar films so that's why you
know it's fair to say that you don't
feel it any honestly my favorite one was
the first one I didn't know I didn't
know I didn't realize I feel like I
should have known
I've been following that child actor all
the way who told me that all the time
you cuz me I'm an idiot I'm looking at
the scene and they they pay special
attention to me folks I'm like I thought
that was similar first and thinking the
guy was on the Skype call me why did
showing this dude so much and then the
fun that out I'm like wow that's so cool
for that guy though yeah yeah see the
only kid who gotta come back I think so
yeah now him let him he got boo he got
made fun of a lot
bring him back you said look at the
camera like this yeah me that was cool
though that's really awesome for him you
just playing some other guy yeah you'd
play another you still gotta make a
cameo with the other Ben act yeah the
talk directly to your character from the
movie in the stuck on him for a while so
you got this yeah I guess the
unfortunate part was he did not get to
grow up looking as chiseled the guy
who's playing what if they got all the
kids from the mini series to play all
the adults no one probably would have
watched me and Emily the Stephen King
cameo I think is one of the more obvious
yes your eggs yeah I mean is this
something you can't really miss so did
you see no you know who it is his
dialogue was Kudo I mean there's very
few authors whose face is that famous
you are living today you know like I've
heard the name Dean Koontz a million
times I didn't know what it looked like
until I saw this yeah it's like JK
Rowling and the Stephen King or the two
faces that yeah I know what they look
like you know I haven't read most of
their stuff I thought the Stephen King
cameo was fun yeah like I actually
really liked that bit his endings don't
always stick the wind yeah that's like
it's like good to make fun of yourself
and then also have fun and dialogue yeah
I thought was cool I think people were
surprised by Stephen King's acting but
I've seen him act plenty he's a good
actor I mean he's not like a great actor
he's exactly like for the littlest roles
he's really good at them have you ever
seen the movie creep show a long time
ago one of the main storylines anthology
he was the star of one of those and I
think he wrote that movie too so that
makes why he was able to be in there but
yeah I've always enjoyed Stephen King's
acting it's serviceable for what we
needed this is pattern on the skateboard
from the Overlook Hotel carpet there's
no way you could pick that out the first
night you'd have to see the movie
multiple times to even because your
attention isn't at the bottom of the
skateboard know when that scene so
that's one that is easy to miss I don't
know if they caught it their team caught
it or they couldn't unless they've seen
a multiple time yeah because they were
sort of still of it and I was like yeah
I know know it it seems like something
that could be so my knew that they could
just read into it yeah Easter Egg one it
might not be the the patter from the
carpet first of all you probably
remember the pattern from the carpet and
then to try to piece that together I
don't know maybe maybe maybe looper
maybe maybe
Pennywise tributes to Tim Curry with the
clowns yeah that to me I definitely
picked up on but I wasn't exactly sure I
saw it and I was like oh is that and
they could just be other clowns but then
they talked about the clothing that's
pretty I missed it because I went to
they got this it experience here they
recreate that whole haunted house okay
you got to spend it thing you walk in
and you actually walk through the
spinning clowns and go in the mirror
room yeah that's that's what I was
thinking of sorry I wasn't even thinking
about you know maybe that's a cameo or a
reference whatever like that cuz I'm
like that's exactly but I walked through
it I was I was like that's a they happen
to me it was he bumped into and I bumped
into Mary's like he did I wasn't even
paying attention to it oh I missed that
one
I'm sorry true maybe next time yeah
there's not gonna be a next time
the crazy one though is the mom that
played Eddie's mom yeah also played
Eddie's wife I feel that's genius flew
over my head that completely revised
because that's something that dead they
know people are gonna miss unless you
really hone in the engine you're not
gonna pick up on it I was like oh she's
a kid - Eddie's yeah yeah yeah she's
just similar I didn't know that was this
same exact actress that's big that's
really cool that's a big whoever decided
that you're a genius I'll be insulting
saying that's big I'm just saying but
you know what is there to be literally
oh you're talking about how it's a big
deal what they said big I think
physically they said physically big they
see what they were talking about I'm
nice proper terminology through if
you're gonna be here don't worry alright
fine fine fine
she was sizable is that better
she's giant so the thing reference their
thing reference is pretty obvious I was
wondering if the line was through I was
heard her Russell's voice in my head
when but then I'm
that the last thing he says to try not
to say it you're right he was funny
exactly but yeah I've ever thing
reference was pretty cool I didn't pick
up on that like oh he developed a new
fear it chapter one they tease that this
is where it's coming from
I don't recall any specific references
to the thing other than when that just
appeared but that would make sense we
don't need to see every part of their
backstory on each other's far enough to
pick up on at the torso thing how long
ago did she hit chapter one when was it
did is that's the last time you saw it
and you remembered it well enough yeah
because I remember when they went to the
three doors and opened the one they sold
his cheek hanging so now when they
opened it door again and they see feet
walking my brain automatically connected
because you heard her voice ooh damn
like I don't remember that from itchy
yeah I always thought a chapter one the
one time in the theaters too but I
remember the door choices but I know
anything behind those doors thinking
which one to go with to and go to one
and then you see her hanging
do you remember what exactly what
happened in that scene and then you see
the feet walking oh that's that's what a
feet went that's really cool yeah that
was nope that was though one of my
favorite chapter two was with the dog
the dog was the best dog starting to
fall for like babies is the puppy that
was whole it is the turtle
I was hoping they'd go full turtle I've
heard about the turtle see the thing is
I heard everyone take away the spider
and do different things so I thought
they're gonna take away the spider and
then maybe have a turtle but the spider
was there so yeah there's so many wise
his head in this pleasure
okay the next it remake or the it
prequel which I adhere is rumored and
actually doing something like that put
the turtle on there you got a commit we
got to go full term I feel like if it's
a prequel to the turtle has to be there
yeah but what else you gonna talk about
yeah what else you get to talk about you
gotta have the turtle man lately the
beer show where they're Turtles cosplay
outfits where's the turtle man I like
turtles like it's gotta be something
like that
chapter turtle I can't wait man I seen
it if they call it that I seen it I died
first in line and only yeah I was a
review
give more positive you automatically
give me what I wanted more turtle stuff
oh well this was fun thanks looper for
putting this together hey guys you can
subscribe to loopers channel if you
haven't done so already make sure to
subscribe to drew I call you drew all
right you going by true
that's hashtag struggle nation channel
so ECOMOG I don't know when you changed
it
whatever your ECOMOG on some platforms
awesome yeah you know your brain doesn't
is confusing you know subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell hey let's give a patron the de
shout out to a man named Niraj Krishnan
Niraj he's from new jersey handsome
fellow
ladies the guy just lost about 15 pounds
down so he is looking sexy so if you're
in New Jersey and you're looking for
some hot Indian action it up Jabbok away
my brother he lives in California you
have better odds of him Niraj lose 20
more pounds and then I guarantee you
you'll get all the ladies you want you
think 15 is good enough no you can't
just stop there you got to keep going
dude keep losing that weight get a
six-pack it works does it no druid no
unfortunately take it off Giroux no
youtube show it's a Niraj show Niraj
what he asked to aspire to we get
age-restricted if you want now my egos
gonna really go down if you should take
off your shirt over and if a Niraj sends
me a shirtless photo too clearly I'm
just jealous of you man I'm sorry you
know I love you I got in trouble for a
mean shout-out recently hopefully you
get them just being satirical